[Music]
are the raiders a little bit obsessed
and paranoid yes they apparently are lee
mayok the daughter of raiders gm mike
mayok posted this during the scouting
combine had a quick bite with daddy goes
to use the restroom and ops to take his
super secret draft binder with him to
the bathroom
rather than leave it with me for
literally two minutes hashtag rude
hashtag kinda smart that was a point
that was reiterated
last week when mayok and raiders coach
john gruden sent
all the scouts home through the draft
because of
issues and concerns about not knowing
who to trust in the building chris i got
a theory on this that relates more to
john gruden than mike mayok i don't
think this is about charles i think this
is about inevitability these people are
all going to be fired and i think in
gruden's mind just get rid of them now
just send them home now they're going to
be gone after the draft these are reggie
mckenzie guys he's already gone they're
going to be gone let's just let them go
now so we don't have to worry about who
they're really loyal to because we know
they have no reason to be loyal to us
yeah i think that's very fair i don't
think you're totally off uh with that
assessment i think there's probably a
lot of truth to that you know the first
thing i'd like to say is you know area
scouts things like that that are in a
building for the nfl draft listen
they're not doing anything they're just
sitting in rooms watching the draft too
you know they're there just to be kind
of part of the draft party
maybe
maybe once in a while you know the pro
player personnel guy or the gm comes out
to ask a area scout one little question
whatever it may be but like i said the
dude all the homework the due diligence
everything like that it's done the
information has been supplied to mayok
gruden and the other powers that be
there in oakland but as i said to start
the show at seven o'clock i mean come on
this is the biggest
biggest draft in the history of the
oakland raiders it's huge i mean it's
three first-round picks they traded away
coil mac last year they're leaving
oakland they're going to las vegas
they're trying to get a team that's you
know worthwhile to sell tickets there
you know john gruden didn't have a great
first year he's got a 10-year 100
million dollar contract they want that
all to work out so he didn't want
anybody in there that yes he probably
didn't know personally and has no feel
for what the makeup of that person is
and he doesn't want any rumors getting
out of that building and getting into
the public or the media about a player
they might be hot on or a player that
they're not hot on and i think that's
really what it's all about at the end of
the day so i really really probably a
wise decision for them to do it
but when you look at the idea that the
hayes in the barn they have all the
information they need from the area
scouts how every team should do that
then why take any risk that you've got a
double agent lurking that you have
somebody who may be thinking about his
neck job not his current job just send
them all home i mean my point is there
are other ways to secure the information
without doing something that conspicuous
that makes people think you're even more
dysfunctional than you already are and
chris when i hear you explain the
dynamics that resulted in this the idea
that they're going to make these changes
they're in the process of getting rid of
the reggie mckenzie scouts i i go back
to last year and i think why didn't they
just get rid of mckenzie when they hired
john gruden yeah why didn't they hire
mike mayok then why didn't they fire the
scouts after last year's draft i mean
there's a certain amount of work you
have to rely on because they've been
doing it into january from when college
football season began so the natural
time to make the changes is after the
draft but why didn't they do this all a
year ago yeah it's a very good question
you know i don't know if it had
something to do with reggie mckenzie's
contract status maybe john gruden
thought okay i like some of the things
i've seen reggie mckenzie do maybe he
thought he could work with them i don't
know you're exactly right but to your
point and what your first question was
is why don't why don't more people do it
you're right i think there's there's
certainly
like i said uh there's no place for the
area scouts a lot of the times during
the draft they're just sitting outside
why the decision makers are in some
meeting room calling the shots or
you can go the new england route and
really never let the area scouts in on
what the hell is going on in the
organization anyways so that that's
that's the other way i mean uh my
experience up in new england with two
drafts was yeah area scouts were there
to partake but they really had
absolutely no idea how the board stacked
up for the new england patriots as far
as position ranks or top 50 players in
the draft whatever it may be so they
were all just about supplying the
information and then bill nick casario
mr kraft you know uh
another pro player personnel guy they
were the only guys allowed in the main
room to see the information everybody
else is in the dark
and
there's a good reason for that because
the patriots are the masters of the do
your job mindset the top down
what is your role this the area scouts
have no role in compiling the draft
board they have no reason to even know
what the draft board is their role is to
gather information so it can be supplied
to the people who'll be making decisions
and and that's why you don't send them
home they have other work they're doing
independent of executing the draft
they're doing work for next year's draft
they're doing work for next year's free
agency or they're doing work for guys
who may become available as more and
more players are churned out of the
bottom of rosters because we know once
the draft happens what occurs veteran
players who thought they had jobs soon
find out they don't have jobs so it's
all about getting the most out of your
assets and bill belichick confident
enough that he knows what he can assign
to these folks that's what gruden and
mayok should be doing wall these people
off you're still paying them give them
jobs that will lead toward the goals
that you're going to have the objectives
that you need going forward the rest of
the work doesn't end just because this
is draft week surely you can find stuff
for these guys to do
independent of them knowing anything
about your draft plans i mean it really
is a counterproductive level of paranoia
because you have gainfully employed
individuals that can be doing something
for you of value this week instead of
sitting at home yeah i mean yeah i'm not
going to argue on any of that where i
would just push back to say in this in
this particular case okay we just talked
about new england well you know a lot of
those guys have been in the new england
pipeline they understand how it works
you know john gruden mike mayok i think
just in defending them in this situation
they don't know these people yet these
are not their guys so they're they're
not in the you know they shouldn't have
been there and they shouldn't be there
they shouldn't be pushed out the door
the week of the draft they they could do
a hell of a lot of damage from september
to march if you now you're pushing them
out they should have been if you i guess
my point is if you have somebody that
you don't trust to the point where you
would send them home the biggest week of
the year why the hell were they over
there in the first place well because
there's lots of people that trust and
they talk to people it's the nfl as you
know it's a very small circle and you
know to go old school on you like the
movie here okay you know mayok and
gruden are in the trust tree uh they're
in you know meet the parents they're in
the circle of trust okay they're
together
i don't think they know who else yes
exactly i see you gaylord over there yes
uh but yes i i you know they're trying
to find out who else can be in the trust
tree with them and right now i don't
think they trust anything they realize
how big this draft is and they're
keeping two or three guys around right
who obviously they've had some dialogue
with and they do trust in this situation
so other than that i think they were
afraid of probably the guys they are
keeping around letting them uh be a part
of some of the decisions they're scared
that they might leave and talk to a
scout that they trust and even though
gruden might not know him gruden doesn't
trust them so things like that i think
they're just trying to end the you know
the connection there of maybe some guys
that are in the trust tree with other
guys they don't know who are outside of
that if that makes any sense when all i
i well look if you can't trust someone
in the trust tree they shouldn't be in
the trust tree there's a level of
paranoia here that i believe is
counterproductive and it gives us an
insight into the mind of your old head
coach he carries around a lot of crap
that he shouldn't carry around and it's
a distraction from the important things
and he's worried about what this guy's
going to say what that guy's going to
say what people outside are saying about
me look just focus on doing your job
take a page from bill belichick and set
up your organization so people know what
their job is so people can show up for
work and they're not in the trust tree
and so be it they're not trying to climb
onto the trust tree because there's you
know the the the the trunk of the tree
has been greased like a pole in
philadelphia so they can't i mean how
hard is it to set up your building so
people you don't trust don't have access
to information that that they shouldn't
have well they're in the process of that
and it was a lot of stuff that john
gruden had to take care of when he got
in the building so yeah he left you know
some of the personnel people in place
and now he's got a guy that he trusts as
his gm and mike mayok and they're
they're going through that but i don't
think they wanted to cut the cord you
know right when they hired mike mayok of
course because like you said there's
unfinished business they got area scouts
and things that it's all in the middle
of the draft process they don't want to
cut it dry right there and end it and i
think that obviously gruden thought
maybe there was something he could work
out with a reggie mckenzie when he first
got there so this is all part of the
process it's still only year one uh or
finishing up year one for john gruden
here and they're getting this right so
i'm not mad at this yeah are they gonna
miss out a little bit on the fact that
oh maybe there's a guy they wanted to
draft from florida state in the fourth
round and they're not sure and they got
a question between him and some other
guy at mississippi state let's see
and let's say and now they want to go to
the area scout and ask a few little
intricate details yeah they're going to
miss out on that aspect but they're
obviously willing to be able to deal
with that other than you know maybe a
leak getting out the door and who their
number four pick might be
i got two quick points and then we have
to take a break first of all i think
john gruden kept reggie mackenzie around
last year so he would have someone to
blame if what happened last year
happened last year which is khalil mack
gone amari cooper gone the team four and
12.
reggie mckenzie took the fall for it and
if he gets fired on the way in the door
you don't have reggie mckenzie to blame
for it as directly as you would if he's
still there and his fingerprints can be
placed on some of these moves even
though these were all gruden moves
secondly i think what they did last week
is a sign that they are beginning to
crack under the pressure of having to
take those three first round picks and
turn them into khalil mack amari cooper
type players because the whole purpose
of the lottery is when you scratch off a
winning ticket you find a way to keep it
you don't throw it back in for more
tickets they've thrown back two winning
lottery tickets one winning lottery
ticket and one who really knows but it
was more winner than loser they've
thrown them back for fresh tickets and
they better scratch the right tickets
this time or a lot of people are going
to look really bad and i feel like
they're feeling the pressure of that
chris and i think that that helps
explain why we are where we are yeah i'm
not going to disagree with you i think
you make a lot of good points and i'm
i'm sure some of that is true but i like
how we've gone with you know tickets and
trust tree for this segment though as
really two staples to tie this all
together
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports